12-time world champion demetrius johnson
makes his much anticipated debut at one
championship
the one for the highway
[Applause]
champion
well obviously i'm the number one
container i got a date with adrian
a world title showdown for the flyweight
gold
well adriano said demetrius was
dominating ufc i was dominating one
championship
[Applause]
everybody knows who is the best in this
division
if you know you know if you didn't you
know now
okay what i can take a knee to the jaw
get right back up
the rematch we've all been waiting for
[Music]
please don't get involved
what is poppin fam it is monday morning
august 22nd
how's everybody doing everybody good out
there great grand wonderful let's get
started lots to cover a lot going on in
the fight world we had a few big events
over the weekend
and the thick boys squad here decided to
do not one but two calabasas fight
companions it sounds like a good idea
until you realize the bkfc card is four
hours long now thank god that uh we
lined up bert kreischer who could talk
forever and he's so fun i didn't realize
that it was four hours because bert i
thought i thought we were like an hour
and a half into it to be honest when it
was over bird is so goddamn entertaining
one of my favorite people on the planet
absolutely love burt kreischer
the guy's just
killing it he's absolutely blown up and
for him to spend four hours with our
dumbasses the day of his wife's birthday
shows you what kind of person bird is
he's the best absolutely love burke
crusher if you haven't watched it go
check it out now
uh
not a lot of fight coverage just gonna
be completely honest now that we really
only paid attention the main event which
was mike perry versus michael venom page
um
you know first time really getting into
a bare knuckle but uh bert kreischer and
matt matrione were just
fantastic man they're both so damn good
and uh
yeah those those boys got drunk i'm
professional and i knew i had to do
another fight companion that was gonna
be three hours long so i
i guess i took it easy for me i took it
easy
maybe two drinks yeah i thought we're
gonna all be just gone by that point i
could i mean we can't you gotta come
back that night you just can't
you just can't man but bert did his
burnt thing man and he's the best he
brought his own uh concoction he had
some
key lime pie freaking
flavoring that he put into his uh
tequila
he's a professional he's the machine
he's rolling stone's number one uh party
college guy of all time so i expect him
to come with that stuff
it was fun though man that that bare
knuckle is um
you know it's different than
usually what we cover with the ufc but
uh it's entertaining man and i thought
you know for the most part um
especially in the main event mike perry
and michael van page
um you know you could make some bank
betting on uh the dogs this weekend if
you took mike perry and you took leon
edwards you were going sizzler this
weekend because i'll see two big dogs
but also the other dogs and obviously
vegas has these lines and
also the way vegas works is especially
when it comes to fighting not football
not baseball not hockey not basketball
the ufc a lot of times when you look at
the lines or even just mma in general or
boxing is you usually favors the more
famous guy with the biggest fan base
and also you know i would be willing to
bet
when hamza nate diaz fight nate diaz has
such a rabid fan base that line now is
going to go down to you know plus 200 no
but i guarantee you it's not going to be
you know minus 2200 for hamza because
nadia's rabid fan base isn't come out
and force and bet on nate like they
always do and there's that loyal fan
base so i would imagine that line moves
and also vegas knows this there's no
other sport like mixed martial arts with
these guys who have rabid fan bases so
they do those lines for a reason they
want you to bet on them and the most
famous guy gets a lot of movement so
um you know if you look at this past
weekend with mike perry michael venom
page
you know mike van page is i would say a
more well-known guy internationally
definitely more credentialed definitely
fought in bigger fights you know spot
for world championships stuff like that
um
and when this fight was announced i
thought to myself god awful fight for
mike perry but as we got close to the
fight you think it is bare knuckle mike
perry does have the
upper hand as far as experience goes he
has one bare knuckle fight that he did
win but still more expensive than
michael venom page
it's in a microphone page you know
backyard it's a home game for him it was
in london so you know i guess you check
that box for microphone and page or not
or that's a lot of pressure on them and
you know this fight came to fruition
because mike pearce supposed to fight
somebody else
and then um
you know that fell out and then uh uh
david hayes the the you know world
famous boxer hit up michael venom page
and he was like yeah i'm down and
bellator grant him the access to do it
so we got this kind of amazing one-off
fight
and
you know when you're betting on it
and like i said when the fight was
announced like that's a tough fight for
mike perry you know the the precision
the timing the skill of michael venom
page just give me a nightmare for him
but then as you get closer like it's
bare knuckle man it's not mma it's not
boxing it's not kickboxing
you know a lot of the the bare knuckle
has to do with guys just being freaking
tough man and mike perry might be the
toughest guy in the roster so you you
had that dog mentality and mike perry
made it a freaking fight man made it a
[ __ ] a brawl and that's what you got
to do with michael venom page you can't
sit back and let him get all fancy and
pick you apart and mike perry knows this
and did he eat some shots sure but in
that first round he was the guy that you
know did the most damage landed the
biggest shot wobbled mike venom page sat
him down and then you know went to that
bonus round and
this is being three whiskey's deep and
you know burke chrysler making me laugh
and freaking matt material making me
laugh and just watching it from that
perspective we all had mike perry
winning that fight i think even you
before they announced it chin gave to
mike perry right yep
um you know mike pay had the swelling of
the of the cheek there which i've been
there look up marlowski pictures my
cheek would not stop swelling up it's
just because the blood can't leave
doesn't necessarily mean you broke your
jaw anything like that it's just when it
swells up like that um you know
it might i mean it looks like i have a
baseball in my freaking mouth
you know i remember it being worse for
some reason but
yeah uh yeah it got worse you know a few
days after that but um that's pretty big
though yeah it went down you know a few
days later out of
i would assume that um
you know mike perry today is fine it's
not a broken jaw anything like that but
i was happy for mike perry when that
fight also if your bare knuckle fighting
championship you kind of want mike peter
to win that fight because he's your guy
michael and paige i would assume maybe
down the road does one more but in
general he's a bellator guy you know
then mike perry has gone the ufc route
and i heard his his manager i think it's
uh malki uh talking about how mike perry
does want to get back to the ufc that's
his goal to get back to ufc so you know
mike perry is a bare knuckle guy through
and through so as far as bare knuckle
goes your guy won your guy wanting beat
a huge name and i would assume for mike
perry to a bigger fight uh his next form
who is that going to be it's been tough
to get a bigger name michael venom page
they're weird that was to me just the
going into it the lead up the fight
being announced there was so much
interest in that fight um just because
two conflicting styles man but it was a
fun fight it was a fun fight man
great time really good time uh then you
did have ufc this weekend
let's get right into it you had ufc 278
um
i would say overall in the card you know
obviously the three main fights were the
with the build up going into it the the
thing that sold everybody the rest of
the card was all right um
you know
a lot of decisions on this card
especially on the prelims on espn you
know the
the
the main prelims you know all drawls
well i should say one draw three
decisions you know so it's tough going
into that and then uh you kick off the
the main card which we did a fight
campaigning for if you haven't seen it
yet it's with sam tripley bradley martin
uh matt mitrione and myself
there's the boys there and uh
you know
sam tripley is a guy that um
he just brings it he
and the reason i uh booked him on this
he's been asking do it for a while and
finally we had a spot open the reason i
booked him
is because i knew the energy of me and
matt coming off a four-hour podcast for
bare knuckle with bert kreicher you're
gonna need someone to carry their weight
and sam will carry all the weight sam is
that guy you can just go
uh john f kennedy jr and you got an hour
of content you know what i'm saying or
dude what happened with that jfk thing
you believe there's one shooter and then
he's freaking running you know so that's
why he was booked on that show he's the
best sam's absolute best he's also the
reason i got started in comedy gave me
my first shot at the comedy store so i
absolutely love sam triple he's one of
the last og comics left he's like a 90s
comic
and of course bradley martin who uh just
brings a different flavor to the show
and then mitrione michonne texted me
yesterday i was like hey man sorry that
last companion i was tired man for the
first one i was like you were fine dude
he's good yeah don't get out of your
head man you're so much fun matt's great
dude that's absolutely great
matt's such a big fan of bert i didn't
know that anyways i can't believe bert's
on today i'm like
birdie yeah man i was like you didn't
see the flyers i did dude it's insane
yeah he's the best
so i think it was a good time for matt
matt just
you know you put up that meat ahead bat
signal and he answers the call man so i
absolutely love matt um
but you know
overall
into i mean tyson pedro did his thing he
was a big favorite right um
you know there wasn't a lot going on on
the fight card there's not there's not a
lot to be excited about so yeah tyson
pedro was a big favorite
beat the guy's ass in a minute right so
like all right
in the next fight and then you get into
the main really the main card what
everyone bought the pay-per-view for you
have mourab versus jose aldo
and um
it was a disappointing fight if you're a
jose aldo fan he just never pulled the
trigger
you know he guaranteed he wouldn't get
taken down and
jose you were a man of your word you
didn't really get taken down he did
eventually but it was that seems like
that was to him that was a win as long
as he had taken down
he was all good the shame in all of this
is jose aldo didn't need to take this
fight because they told him he would get
the winner of tj al germain and now
you're back in the queue in the
bantamweight division and it's [ __ ]
packed it's so packed so they got to
figure out what to do jose now
from rob there's nothing but positive
coming out of this fight you know he's
on a crazy win streak
um you know he's not the most
entertaining fighter
you know i i would if going in this
fight told me he would have better light
kicks than jose aldo i'd tell you out of
your goddamn mind but he definitely did
so now he's on a what one two three four
five six seven eight win uh streak his
last loss was to ricky simone big win
for ricky simone who actually submitted
him uh in a guillotine choke so that's a
huge win for ricky simone reach
someone's one of those quiet dogs man
yeah he's quiet
yep coming up there um so it's a huge
win for him let's take a little break
from breaking down all this ufc 278 leon
edwards got it done baby i bet you he's
sleeping so good man i bet he's sleeping
so
freaking good now he's back in london
he's in his home bed but you know why
sleeping good not just because his home
bed because he sleeps on a helix
mattress that's right helix my friend's
a helix listen helix is a premium
mattress brand that provides tailored
mattresses that are built just for your
thick ass all right it includes 14
unique mattresses including a collection
of luxury models mattress for big tall
small tiny light heavy whatever you got
we got the mattress just for you um
helix knows there's no better way to
test out a new mattress than by sleeping
on it all right that's why they offer a
100 night risk free trial try your new
helix mattress see everybody just see if
you dig it if you don't which you're
going to but if you don't they will
gladly pick it up and give you a full
refund that's right that's how freaking
good helix sleep mattresses are all you
do is take a short little quiz and then
you're matched your thick ass to the
perfect mattress that's built just for
you soft medium firm your side sleeper
back sleeper stomach you move around we
got it you're covered baby we got you
covered helix is offering you guys up to
200 off all matched orders and two free
pillows for you guys go to
helixsleep.com
with helix better sleep starts right now
college football is back baby it's time
to enjoy the tradition there's nothing
i'd rather watch in college football
it's my favorite form of football better
than the pros
if you like to watch and make bank do it
with my friends at draftkings sportsbook
to celebrate the best time of the year
right now new customers can bet just
five dollars on any team and get two
hundred dollars in free bets instantly
win or lose that's enough action can
also place the same game parlay for a
shot at even bigger payout just combine
multiple bets into one like which team
will get the win which teams score first
and so much more draftking is a safe
secure reliable best of all you can
deposit withdraw your cash whenever you
want a good bet would be bet on usc
there they got all the players now man
usc is gonna be a force download the
draftking sportsbook app right now use
promo code shop show sch a b show bet
just five dollars on college football
and get two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly that's code shop show only at
draftking sportsbook 21 or older in most
eligible states but age varies by
jurisdiction lgbt restrictions apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for terms and
resources gambling problem call 100
gambler in tennessee call or text
tennessee redline at 1-800-889-9789
in new york call 8778 hope ny or text
hope ny to
467-369 one per new customer minimum
fighter wager 200 issued as eight 25
free bets that's draftkings promo code
shop show but uh for marab you know
i hear some people going oh let's do
marab who beat a legend jose aldo versus
chito vera
i don't think that's the move i know the
division is tied up and if you want to
fight both those guys soon you could do
that
but when you look at it
you know
cheetos coming off a straight up
highlight reel
ko i would say it was the best ko this
year
you know meatball in uk had a big one
but she's not fighting top
you know tear fighters right now
for what cheeto did to dominic cruz who
maybe the best ben weight of all time to
absolutely you know
kick him in the face and break his nose
when he's never been finished like that
that's a
feather in your cap to say the least so
he's coming off crazy momentum rob's
momentum i don't think anyone's walking
away from that go now that guy's a world
beater you know it was a kind of a
boring fight it wasn't what we were
expecting so you know morop's six
cheetos five
you have corey sanhedrin fighting of
josiah fighting i would assume
uh the the problem is is josado beat
cheeto you know not too long ago mara
beat josiado so if you're doing the
rankings right now marab six cheetos
five
does marab jump up to three
and then cheetos stays at five
that doesn't seem right to me
um
you know marab versus cheeto is a good
fight it's you know i don't think you do
a fight night i guess especially cheeto
cheese a bigger name now especially what
he did to
um
you know
yeah dominic cruz so
listen
cheeto's my boy i don't want that fight
for him again learn from jose aldo aldo
had all this momentum three fight win
streak probably was gonna get the winner
of al jermaine and tj now you're back in
the queue now you jump to six and you
gotta work your way back up you know so
it's a nightmare man so i think for
cheeto he chills i would turn that fight
down there's not a lot of upside to it
and i wait for the winner of cory santa
hagin's song or i wait for the winner of
uh uh peter yan and suga or you wait for
the winner of al germain and tj
every fight i just those three fights
just mentioned to you are all way bigger
names way funner fights
stylistically marab is going to be a
problem for anybody you know he's just
not the most entertaining guy but he's a
[ __ ] winner so he i would avoid him
if i'm cheeto not that he can't beat him
but stylistically name recognition it
doesn't make a lot of sense if i'm
cheetos team i'm just going nah i'm good
man we we've beat freaking uh frankie
edgar we killed frankie yeager you know
we've beat sugar shawn huge names so
beat sugar shawn beat frankie yeager
freaking
one most legendary head kick kos of all
time til leon edwards said hold my two
piece in the soda check this out right
so
for cheeto coming off that huge ko of
dominic
huge ko uh uh frankie edgar did work
against rob font that was an absolute
annihilation and main event
there's just a lot more momentum on
cheeto side than marab there's just a
ton more i know murad beat jose who beat
cheeto but cheeto has passed morab at
this point as far as value so if i'm
cheetos team i'm saying we're good marab
go fight somebody else you're not he's
and he's a [ __ ] tough match-up but
not a very big name that's the problem
um so overall fight wasn't great
um and then you in your co-main event
you had luke rockhold versus paulo costa
i think this fight sold more
pay-per-views the week of than anything
more so than leon edwards kumar who's
been i think the fans were so excited
over paulo costa and luke rockhold just
because the [ __ ] talk going into it luke
rockhold being so open about fighter pay
and kind of going at the ufc and
listen i like when people you know i
like chaos and luke rockhold brought the
chaos and he was very honest about it
and a lot of fighters supported him for
that reason and you know god bless luke
rockhold you know i did mention to him
through text he said listen dude you win
this fight you keep asking for a title
shot there's not a chance in hell
the ufc the ufc brass give you a title
shot after talking all that [ __ ] because
if
you think you have some sort of
power now or momentum now think when
you're champ dude so i
my advice with him was now maybe he
thought this is my last one no matter
what
so
rightfully so god bless you do your
thing because you went off you know oh
it's a great send-off but if your goal
was to fight again talking to [ __ ] ain't
the way to go because they're gonna try
and get you out of there and they're not
gonna give you a freaking title shot so
teach its own i enjoyed it and um you
know dana did a good job navigating his
way through that now let's get to the
fight
going in you know
i told you guys my draftkings parlay if
you want to make some bank the chance of
it happening not good but you take the
dog you take jose aldo luke rockhold and
leon edwards only two only one of those
gentlemen one of the three and he won
with basically 56 seconds left so it was
a stretch but that's why it pays so much
money because you are
going against the odds that's why you
know parlays are so hard to you know win
because you got to win three big fights
you bet on three dogs what's the chance
of three dogs winning not good but
that's why you make banks son so when i
give you those that's to say hey it's a
hell mary but that helmet hairy cat if
that somebody catch that hell maybe
we're going sizzler daddy you know so
with luke rockhold paulo costa
you know going the fight
uh bisping did come out say this he's
very close with luke rockhold's uh
trainer um
yeah yeah jason perello who's brilliant
at out of ruca down there in orange
county um you know so bisping is very
close to him and talked to him and you
know pillow was completely honest and
said listen you know he hasn't trained
that much
um as much as i guess he wanted to and
also really didn't spar he thinks he can
get through this with not sparring
now when you take that we take that much
time off
you know there's going to be some
consequences and the consequence was
i know we can say altitude and salt lake
city does have high altitude but still
listen luke rockhold is a dog he's a
veteran he's used to that stuff he's
fought in those environments before
that wasn't something where halfway
through the first round he's like oh
[ __ ] man this altitude is killing me no
no he knows what the [ __ ] is going on um
so
you know i don't know if he put his best
foot forward in a lot of that fight you
know he looked completely exhausted um
you know he's working with a breathing
coach which
matt alluded to on companions a little
bit of a red flag it's a little bit
alarming um and he just it looked like
father time caught up with him looked
like fallout time finally caught up with
him
putting his uh you know
hands on his knees turning his back it
was tough man now
thank god he's fighting paulo costa
who's also not known for his cardio and
is also fighting at a higher elevation
so he's not exactly the cardio king so
would we get a phenomenal fight an inter
i should say an entertaining fight
because they're both exhausted but both
have crazy heart and i think for luke
for this be his last fight
you know although the body isn't the
same
luke rockhold that it was you know five
years ago or six years ago when he was
you know
probably the best middleweight on the
[ __ ] planet you know but the the
heart is still there the mind was still
there and you you
have to show some sort of appreciation
for a guy who let's be honest
has a lot of haters you know he gets a
lot of hate hey because the way he looks
because the way he acts right he's very
brash very arrogant
on camera in person he's a great guy but
on camera and the the the sound bites
that he gives off you're not gonna win
over a lot of dudes you know so luke
rockhold has always been that guy who's
insanely talented
just happens to be a legit ralph lauren
[ __ ] model
and so you know and you're cocky too
you're not getting a lot of fans you
know but people are gonna tune and see
you lose
so for luke you know i thought it was
kind of uh
you know it was kind of uh it was very
romantic
and i'm not talking about when he rubbed
his blood all over polycaster's face i'm
talking about for luke who has been a
guy that a lot of people
um
didn't enjoy or you know kind of [ __ ] on
all the time because of his uh attitude
and the way he looks
you know for for the fans to give him a
stand ovation and him cry and stuff like
that and him to let his guard down and
finally you see kind of a glimpse of the
real luke rockhold who's a good guy
the people i know as far as you know
you're talking about
uh brian cowan mitrione uh tark i see
these guys some of the best people i
know on the [ __ ] planet if they're
friends with luke and like jake shields
is trust me he is a good guy it what you
see on camera isn't the real luke
rockhold and that's why i vouch for luke
because he's actually a good person but
you guys don't see that and i get the
hate so um i thought it was very
uh
hollywoodlike for a guy of his magnitude
to go out on his shield and show his
heart even though he is exhausted
um it was an entertaining fight
entertaining fight and i said this on
the fight companion if i think paul
costa's ranked uh
five or six and luke rockhold was
technically on ranked but uh whoever is
fighting paulo class the next is foaming
at the dick to get their hands on him
you saw so many holes in his game you
saw you know cardio is an issue
you saw you know his grappling
capability stuff like that so
those killers waiting in line dude i'm
telling you they're foaming at the dick
to do it now is that going to happen i
don't know because it wasn't a big
narrative going into the fight but it
was his last fight on his ufc contract
and now he's talking about fighting jake
paul
driving today i thought about this
you know
there's a reason why all these guys
going after jake paul right
there's a huge reason why they're
calling out jake paul and obviously
the notoriety and the eyeballs you're
gonna get and the the payday you're
gonna get that payday you can get more
than you know he's ever made in his
entire career fighting uh you know
technically a youtuber one time
but i guess if you're paulo costa i'll
look in the mirror and go all right can
i be world champ
well you fought izzy what twice
or once you thought izzy once got
starched right um
you know
it it depends what you're looking for
because once you go to jake paul route
and especially in paul costa's
his age right
he's probably in his prime right now so
if you were to leave and and fight he's
31 at you know middleweight
it's now's the time now's the time when
it's 34 35 those guys can do it but he's
in his prime right now so
um you know
i think he has to ask himself what's the
goal if the goal is to make the most
money possible and get as famous as
possible you fight jake paul but let's
go through the jake paul uh scenario
here so you agree to fight jake paul
which i think jake paul would be down to
do
i also don't think it's a terrible fight
for jake paul surprisingly um
so
jake paul agrees to fight paul costa
let's say paul acosta loses that fight
or wins doesn't matter
where do you go after that
if your goal is to be a full-time
professional boxer and you your first
fight is jake paul
let's just talk through it where do we
go after you fight jake paul
you're gonna fight real boxers
you're gonna fight actual
high-level boxers well that's not career
is it you're 31 that's not realistic
um can you do the fame route where you
fight a jake paul then you besides jake
paul who's gonna fight you
if you beat jake paul it's like a just
like a close decision you might get the
big whale and logan paul and we get
another big payday which then we're
going straight sizzling you could
probably buy the city of rio so that's
cool
um
that's a big if you know if you're to
fight logan if you know he uh comes for
a vengeance for his little brother
it could be a possibility your team
could talk about that um
[Music]
maybe a woodley would do it you know
you're looking at kind of these freak
shows a little bit i'm not calling
really a freak show what i'm calling is
the you're looking at these kind of
spectacles where
there's no blueprint for it so you're
kind of in this weird gray area where
you're hoping these big names
sign on to fight you
but again i i think if you're paulo
costa and you look in the mirror and go
can i actually become champ
i would say no
yuri i'll ask the izzy
um you lost overtory
um you know whitaker's out there
so he hasn't fought whitaker um you have
cardio issues
um you know you've beat ryan hall who
retired yo romero who's in bellator and
then you you lost to the champ pretty
bad uh izzy starched them vittori you
know
kind of dominate him and you know the
weight's been an issue so
i just don't know what he wants to do
and then you get a win over luke
rockhold who you know hasn't fought in
quite some time coming off three losses
you didn't look great that's a guy where
imagine fluke rock hold fought a
victoria or izzy
that fight ain't making out of the
second round bubba i would i would be
one about that fight as may of the first
round that's a tough
tough outing for luke rockhold with
those killers
so if i'm paulo costa yeah i look in the
mirror and go all right
you know the ufc does want to resign me
but what's my chance to become champ not
good
it's completely honest not good um and
then that's not to mention you've
already lost to izzy and marvin vittori
right
what happens if homsat decides to go to
middleweight which is gonna happen
eventually
you can beat hamzat how you beat hamzat
how you beat tom's not dude
you got some problems so
you know i think for paulo costa and his
team i don't know who the [ __ ] his team
is you know everyone talks to his
girlfriend doing a lot of his stuff i'm
just curious you know what the move
would be now if the move to make the
most money possible you know you tease
that jake paul fight and i would assume
jake paul is your huckleberry and he'd
be willing to do that
uh for jake paul
you know he wants the validation of
fight fans
i think if he were to beat a nate diaz
that would definitely swing in his favor
to get more people on board this legit
kind of validation that he says he's not
looking for but we know he's looking for
so if you were to knock nate diaz out
that might do it
um so if you fought a nate diaz
really could fight paulo costa probably
before that yeah nate fights in
september so around the same time so
teach its own you could fight either one
but if polycaster were to fight um or if
jake paul were to fight paul costa
beat him and then and these are big f's
dude so if we were to beat holocaust and
beat nate diaz and you look at jake's
record your people are still gonna be
like dude fight a boxer because even
though these guys are monsters in the
ufc the neighbors are still gonna be you
haven't fought a boxer i haven't fought
a boxer i haven't fought a boxer he's
fighting killers with his experience but
it's a weird road yeah if you're paul
costa i mean you make a ton of [ __ ]
money but just depends what you want to
do man if you're if you're a fighters
fighter and your heart's set on mma you
got to resign with ufc take your chance
to become champ and it is a tough
[ __ ] road you've already lost to
those guys
let's get to the main event
this main event man uh leon edwards
kamar usman you have your second ever
british champion your second ever
british jam in the first being michael
bisping where there's the difference
here
is remember when michael biswing became
world champion he was training out of
orange county california uh at rain and
at ruca i was at rain at the time
and he was with jason perrillo in orange
county
so
although
his main
kind of
meat and bones he was training uh out of
i think it's westlair in uh in the uk i
think it might be in manchester but
either way he did win the ultimate
fighter he did come up in the uk scene
so he's you know
british all the way
the difference is when leon edwards
became champion
he was currently training
out of
you know uh birmingham he was currently
you know all his his win streak his his
life his home
you know everything he does is based out
of birmingham england so he is a
full-on
thoroughbred of a [ __ ] brit to get it
done so it's a l granted bisping's 100
percent [ __ ] british is the the
reason why lee underwood is where he is
today don't get it twisted the the the
the uk scene would not be anywhere
without what michael bisping has done he
is the pioneer he's the [ __ ] rosa
parks of british fighters he's the first
one to become champion first one to win
[ __ ] the ultimate fighter first one
to beat these huge names
his fight with aaron silva one of my
favorite all time
you know so
michael bisping is a straight up
bonafide legend i don't think there will
ever be a uk
i don't say uk fighter but there won't
be a brit more important than michael
bisping
the only difference is leon edwards
actually got this done
training living sleeping breathing out
of birmingham england and so what that
does right if you're a young kid
coming up in england and you know you're
into as they call it football but we
call it soccer right but football makes
so much more sense anyway if you if
you're a young brit coming up
well now you're looking at guyana
edwards who you see at the local pub you
see at the fish and chip store you see
buying [ __ ] wine gums he's just like
you even though he's via jamaica but
really he came up in [ __ ] birmingham
england on the streets rough life single
mom
his dad was shot and murdered right so
for leon edwards more brits are going to
look at him go oh he's just like me
because when bisping got it done
you know i would assume the brits out
there go well he's in orange county he's
hollywood now granted none of this is
true but they're going well he got it
done but he had all the help from orange
county and those big names and those
superstars and those elite coaches and
stuff like that
name the coach that leon edward works
with name the gym he comes out of
nobody nobody me neither so for leon
edwards i just feel like he's going to
inspire not that biz being listen the
reason why leon edwards is here today is
because of michael bisbee the reason
darren till asked menaul you you the
paul craig all the boys the conor
mcgregor for that matter all patti piml
all the [ __ ] boys the reason why they
are where they're at today is because of
michael bisping's hard work showing that
a brit can get it done
so for leon edwards i just feel like
he's going to inspire
so many people now in the scene because
you can see him he's there born and
raised came up came from a small gym
he's done it man and now
the way he got it done
and this is why you hear joe rogan john
anak a lot of other people the bt sport
boys over in the uk shout out to them my
faves
you know the reason why they all say
it's the greatest knockout of all time
which i completely agree with
is because leon edwards won the first
round got the takedown got to mount
insane
but also you got to realize and then he
goes on to get dominated really you know
he wasn't getting his ass what but
wasn't very competitive right he was
going to take down boring fight and so
the next
four rounds
even in the fifth round he's he's not
winning this fight man he's down he's
down three to one clearly and he's also
56 seconds away from
only winning one round against the champ
because he got a trip and you know
landed in mount but didn't do much with
it and then camaro woke up the [ __ ] up
and dominated him
and so you're waiting and it's to me
again this is very hollywood because
leonardo is if you think about his path
to becoming the second
brit to ever do this
it's always been kind of this delay this
long kind of delay unlike anybody else
unlike conor who's catapulted to the
[ __ ] top on like comes out who's
catapulted to the [ __ ] top dare until
you go you know you go through the
[ __ ] list
for for leon edwards to have belief in
himself where remember he saw sight
tyron woodley at the time and then that
fell through and then cove would hit and
then he's supposed to fight homs at
three different times and then you know
he fights uh belial muhammad and then
there's the eye pokes think about all
this waiting all this waiting and your
team's going i'm sure even this team's
like oh this is not looking good for you
to become champ man this is a disaster
no one's had a tougher route to becoming
a world champion the only guy who has a
similar route would be tony ferguson in
his prime remember when tony was doing
the damn thing supposed fight could be
kept falling through kept on through if
that fight would have finally came to
fruition when khabib was champion and if
tony would have pulled off of with 56
seconds left to head kick ko that would
be the only similar
fight where you could say that's the
greatest knockout all the time because
khabib was
never happened never came to fruition so
for leon edwards to constantly conse the
waves just keep hitting him all these
[ __ ] things keep in them keep
preventing from being champion
and then he finally gets his shot in
salt lake city utah high elevation
right finally gets a shot
american fans are kind of like i guess
you come on is going to mop the floor
with this guy first round you're like
all right and then after that you're
like this is what we expect i told you
guys it's going to be a boring fight
pretty spot-on kind of a boring fight
not the most entertaining fight
and then with 56 seconds left to go from
camaro usman beating anderson silva's
all-time title defense record from going
down
bar none the greatest welterweight of
all time
leon edwards just like he's done his
entire career he does it on his time it
takes for [ __ ] ever it's not the most
exciting but somehow he gets it done he
throws a left jab and kamaru spring goes
to parrot and he dips his head and
closes his eyes and then [ __ ] leon
edwards who's been training this since
he was in [ __ ] diapers throws a
[ __ ] high kick and lands shin to chin
and you get a [ __ ] walk off home run
against the guy who was regarded and
going into the fight dancing he's the
goat pound for pound and more in the
world he's better than gsp there's all
these accolades going on tomorrow usman
talking about black panther two in a
[ __ ] split second with 56
seconds left to go in the goddamn fifth
round this [ __ ] brit from birmingham
[ __ ] england
via jamaica throws a left kick that he's
trained his entire [ __ ] life man and
lands it and knocks out one the greatest
ever do it in their [ __ ] prime and
becomes the second british [ __ ]
champion
what is this a movie it's a goddamn
movie man can't be
can't help but be happy for the guy
he doesn't say anything that would piss
you off or rub you the wrong way it's
one of the reasons why american fans
weren't that high on this fight
but it's leon edwards that this is his
path
and i think a lot of fighters can learn
from this leon edwards from day one has
been leon edwards he's not going to talk
[ __ ] he's not very flashy he just trains
his ass off does his obligations for the
media and wins fights that's what leon
edwards does he never fell into the
conor mcgregor you know route where you
know all these guys were like looking at
connor going i better talk [ __ ] i better
do this he went and that's not my thing
man i'll talk a little [ __ ] here it's
fun
he kept making fun of carl uzman the way
he dresses not wearing shirts that's all
fun games he never crossed the line he's
always respectful going he's a great
champion and he did say i don't think
he's the greatest of all time i think
gsp is he goes but maybe that's my
perspective because i came up watching
gsb and i view him higher than camaro
but i look at kamal just like another
fighter i fought camaro before i'm
familiar with him i've never fought gsp
i'm never going to fight gsb so gsp to
from his perspective is the best to ever
do it all good
and then this [ __ ] dude man throws
that goddamn kick with 56 seconds left
and i would love to hear the argument
how it's not the greatest knockout of
all time everyone wrote them off
everyone i was already looking at my
[ __ ] phone going all right here we go
56x left i'm the [ __ ] out of here it's
been the longest day ever this fight's
boring as [ __ ]
and i'm not talking about that chin
we're talking shin to chin
walk off ko home run of a guy who and
this is another reason the greatest
knockout time he's never lost inside the
octagon the only time we've ever seen
kind of trouble
kind of trouble is when gilbert burns
landed a [ __ ] what right hand on him
got a little wobbly weather storm
knocked him out via ground and pound
okay
he's never ever really been in trouble
[ __ ] mopping the floor with everybody
talking about going to light heavyweight
this quiet brit from birmingham [ __ ]
england decides i don't like this story
check this out
insane dude
life-changing for him life-changing
things will never be the same you can
never take that away from ever again
greatest knockout of all time
fantastic man
fantastic
people say oh holly ronda no run didn't
have the striking run and have the
credentials rhonda wasn't you know
regarded you know she she's lost rounds
before or you know she always gets it
done you know she's knocked out some
girls but really you know the arm barn
submissions was her thing and it's and
also
you know
holly lost before that and stuff like
that
uh-uh kamaru swin never lost matter of
fact named last time he's lost a [ __ ]
round
it's insane
it's insane
oh and to add to the story
to add to leon edward's story the ufc
goes hey man we need to get you some
shine before you become you know uh uh
to a title contender and fight for a
world championship here's nate diaz a
rabid fan based man and he this is leon
edwards dude he's right there mops the
[ __ ] floor with nate the ufc is
hoping for a finish
whatever it is 30 seconds in the [ __ ]
fifth round he gets he takes his eyes
off the [ __ ] prize and gets clipped
and that's the narrative oh my god that
fight was 30 seconds longer you know
nate diaz doesn't lose fights he runs
out of time right nobody gave leonardo
which any credit that fight people were
like oh that was trash he lost that
fight what
no go back and what but again that's
leon edwards he's going to do it on his
time
the ways to keep him leon keep hitting
on leon i'll bet on that [ __ ] guy
now
they are going to do that and dana said
this in the uh post fight press
conference
immediate rematch camaros won he's never
lost its first loss you gotta do
immediate rematch
the only caveat with that is coming off
a knockout like that i would assume
camaro is out for quite some time
and there is a back story with leon
edwards in mosvital now mozzarella
getting a title shot makes no sense in
any facet but i could see them doing it
also if you are a leon edwards fan
you would want
leon to fight muslim next because it's
going to extend his reign as champion it
just builds him up even bigger as the
second british champion of all time
because don't get it twisted
you know the chance of leon landing
another
knockoff home run ko head kick it's not
good tomorrow sh sh probably should have
won that fight now there's no luck in
fighting there's no luck camaros i'm
sorry leonard has been throwing that
[ __ ] high kick since he's in [ __ ]
diapers on the street he's done that
kick a million times
uh the coaches said you know going in
in warm-ups that was all set up that was
all pre-determined he was gonna do that
now they wanted to do it earlier that's
not how leon edwards works he does it on
his time so
in the rematch
for sure
[ __ ] kamaru someone's gonna be a big
favorite so the bookies over at bed
online.com opening this one is a minus
350. in part three
atlanta was the plus 285 yeah yeah yeah
yeah the chance of leon beating him
again are not good
so if you're a leon fan you're hoping
that kamar usman goes no that's
definitely my next fight but i'm not
going to fight to
february you know take some time off
shoot the movie that was the plan
man it was a different plan so if you're
liana where it's fan you want that
mozvidoll fight and there's some
backstory there you can build that up it
makes no sense in any facet mazda has
not earned that fight mazda coming off
the kobe covington mishap and all that
[ __ ] and he hasn't won a fight in hot
second it makes no sense but it makes
sense if you're a leon edwards fan and
that's what you want next because i
would imagine he beats mazela doll
he does not beat kamarusman a third time
you know what i'm saying it'd be the
rubber match he i'm sorry he doesn't
beat him a second time he lost the first
one you know
i assume kimarus wins more on it doesn't
take his eye off the prize doesn't get
head kicked this fight goes exactly how
the
the other three out of the five rounds
went this first time so
no matter what who gives a [ __ ] shout
out to leon edwards you did it my man
you did on your terms and everybody here
is proud of you and you have the
greatest knockout in ufc history pretty
[ __ ] cool
shout out to ufc 278 man special night
special night for a hero thick boy too
pulling off two [ __ ] companions is
not easy back to back um it was fun
though
so much fun yeah
i was coming off a four day vacation too
so i was
locked and loaded ready to go
ready to go perfect timing we're just
getting into it man let's take another
little break for all your summer travels
or winter travels fall travels wherever
you're going man
you want to immerse yourself in the
culture and you need to learn the
language don't be that weird buckaroo
who's asking all these questions doesn't
stand the culture that's why babel babel
is the language learning app that sold
more than 10 million subscriptions
thanks to babel it's fun it's easy
bite-sized language lessons there's
still time to learn a new language even
at my age all right with babel you can
listen you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson you can do it in your
car listen to the pod dude whatever you
got going on do it while you're on the
treadmill warming up all right babel is
the way to go it was created over by 150
language experts all right their
teaching methods have been
scientifically proven to be much more
effective with babel you can choose from
14 different languages including spanish
french italian german i learned spanish
because my girls
so mexican plus babble speech
recognition technology helps you improve
your accent all that stuff so you sound
like the real deal you don't sound like
some schmuck all right
there's so many ways to learn with babel
they got you covered man start your new
language learning journey today with
babel and right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you get
an additional three months free that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com use the promo code shop
s-c-h-a-b that's
b-a-b-b-e-l dot com
code is shop fellas confidence can take
you pretty far in life it can also help
in the bedroom especially when it comes
to time to step up to the plate that's
where my friends at blue chew come
flying in blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers same active
ingredients as viagra cialis but in
chewable tablets at a fraction of the
cost take them anytime you want day
night you can plan ahead or be ready
when it's time to go man process super
simple sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers once you're approved you'll
receive your prescription within days
best part it's all done online baby no
visits to the doctor to office no
awkward conversations no way in line
with the pharmacy ship to your freaking
door bluetooth tablets are made in the
us of a prepared and shipped direct to
your door straight little package nobody
has to know your turbocharging that dick
game so if you could benefit from a
little extra confidence when it's time
to go with your lady or your mans blue
chew can help chew it and do it baby you
got a special deal for you guys try blue
chew free when you use the promo code
shop at checkout page just five dollars
shipping and then it comes free that's
bluechew.com promo code schaeb to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details important
safety information and we thank
bluetooth for being a sponsor of the
shop show bluetooth.com promo code shop
um yeah man so
you know this week you don't have any
big ufc fights but you do have one big
ass one championship fight they're
coming to america man
for those of you that don't know
currently one championship is
way more massive than the ufc globally
as far as you know uh internationally
goes one james ship is
dominating the ufc bellator uh ryzen
they completely dominate
so their goal which i asked
who gives a [ __ ] about america and you
know on this week's food truck diaries
we have angela lee who's their champion
and we have um rich franklin who is the
vice president of uh operations over at
one championship so and also you know
ufc legend rich franklin who i grew up
you know idolizing i love rich franklin
do he's wear the brown and pink shorts
and i talked to them about that on this
week's food truck diary so
angela lee and rich franklin come out
and we share some uh tasty breakfast
burritos and uh
i forget i had egg wife was forced to
eat egg whites with rich franklin which
i did not want but i don't want to be
the fat kid so
i did eat half of angelis breakfast
burrito as well so that's cool but that
drops on wednesday and uh
yeah man you know
one championship's goal is to try to
make a splash in the american market
they signed a huge deal with amazon so
you know their first big fight which
makes sense to you know get the the
americans on board they got uh mighty
mouse which is regarded as you know
maybe the best pound-for-pound fighter
of all time and uh he's coming off a
loss to mariah's where if you watch this
fight and i've never seen rice in person
you know so think boy is the official
content provider from one championship
that's the other big announcement so we
provide a lot of content for one
championship we highlight them on the
shows the food trucks all that stuff
then coming to america they did a press
conference in downtown and mark came
with me
so we're in the press section
and
they bring out all their big names right
and mariah walks on the stage i'm like
holy [ __ ] that guy fights at flyweight
this dude is massive and he's [ __ ]
skilled and he comes from nothing his
parents gave him up when he was a
goddamn baby man
he was
he was raised in a [ __ ] orphanage
yeah dude so what happens then well he
gets involved with gangs he's street
fighting and then his friend goes dude
uh out of all the street fighters you're
kind of whooping everybody's ass you
ever tried bjj and he goes let me try it
falls in love with it and [ __ ] harry
is the [ __ ] face of one championship
he absolutely
annihilated mighty mouse whose regard as
the pound pound best ever do it for from
a lot of people uh i don't know if i
agree with that that's that's always up
for debate right depending how you want
to do it he's definitely the
conversation definitely top three is my
number one i usually tend to gravitate
towards the upper uh heavier weight
classes because i feel like there's less
room for error so there's more ways to
lose because these guys hit so hard so
my pound for pound of all time is jon
jones just because he's that light
heavyweight and the love of competition
and the way he's got it and the big
names he's fought and the main events
stuff like that so
but i'm all for you know if you have an
argument for dj so uh you know for dj
you know this this is a big fight man
and it is gonna be you know aired on
amazon you you know if you don't have
amazon definitely get it and watch this
on friday and uh that's your main event
it's a rematch of mariah's for the one
flyweight world championship title fight
um that belt they had the belt in here
that belt is
pretty phenomenal worth a lot of money
worth i was hoping they'd leave it here
so i could melt it and sell it but they
decided not to leave it so you get the
rematch
i gotta be honest
i
i don't know if dj gets it done in the
rematch
uh maurice is a big [ __ ] dude he's a
real problem real problem the whole card
is fun man whole card is fantastic if
you haven't checked out one championship
and if you're new to mixed martial arts
um even if you're not
the one thing that makes one
championship special is you'll see that
each one that they do is like a super
bowl each one will remind you of the
pride days now they do have the same guy
who helped out with pride that puts on
the production the performances of the
walkouts it's very pridish so if you
miss that stuff you're gonna love one
championship nobody does a better job as
far as creating
an atmosphere like it's the [ __ ] pro
ball than one championship their
wildcats are way better than the ufc
i think it's one of the things they do
better in the ufc is their intros and
their walkouts are insane it's just like
the pride days but on steroids [ __ ]
fireworks
screens lights smoke [ __ ]
neon lasers and [ __ ] [ __ ] fantastic i
love that stuff and the card's fun man
card is gonna be super entertaining so
you got mariah's dj rematch tough fight
for dj um they got nongo vs liam
harrison liam harrison again another
brit who's a legend walking the streets
of england
uh also has his own podcast he has his
own podcast called kicking it with liam
harrison um he's a savage man he's an
absolute savage world champion he's
coming off the fight of the year
so this will be a fun one man should be
really really fun um clearly rooting for
him he's you know considered uk's
greatest all-time muay thai guys now is
there a ton of competition no but still
well grace to ever do it out there man
so the whole card is [ __ ] stacked man
the whole card stacked you have uh your
boy chin fighting broad tang man rod tag
if you've never seen rat tang so
ratang's never lost in kickboxing muay
thai uh he fought dj in kind of a
makeshift collab where they did one
round muay thai one round um
mixed martial arts and uh dj did beat
him there uh because he was able to
survive um but still
yeah again all these guys stories are
insane you're talking about a guy again
grew up in southern thailand um you know
he's
[ __ ] uh one of ten children and uh
grew up with nothing man and here he is
here he is one of the best ever do it
man won the very [ __ ] best to do it
you have a former training partner of
mine uh bushesha uh marcus almeida um
who was really close with gentleman who
just passed away who got shot in the
face of that concert brazil
yeah it's a bummer man but he's a guy
who um
ready for this 17-time world champion
17-time world championship guy he goes i
want to see how it goes in mma and here
he is man and he is coming out the gates
hot i think he has two fights or three
fights um and one championship's a good
good home for him man so uh he debuted
his mma last year he's finished all
three of his opponents and uh i would
assume big things for him next man
really big things from next the whole
card is fun man you have anjalee's uh
brother fighting on martial on friday um
yeah so
so the lee family is they're freaks
first of all they're they're from hawaii
they're all hawaiian angelee a
world-class skills also looks like a
goddamn model we had her in beautiful
the boys mouse were drooling and i
thought it was for the breakfast
burritos i didn't i don't i don't see
you know anymore i can't see anything i
just see fighters yeah but you guys were
drooling over the breakfast burritos i
thought
um so you have angela so the whole
family evangely world champion the
christian lee was a world champion he
lost his belt this is a rematch against
okay ray jung right so and then you have
the little sister who's a [ __ ] savage
too no dude and then they're trained by
their dad
nutsos dude nuts their whole fin the
whole family fights basically the whole
family trains and they have a little
brother too i think it's gonna be
yeah savage so it's pretty cool man but
you'll hear her story uh on a food truck
that drops this wednesday and just
promote that the one championship come
to america this first
fight that their america focused even
though i think it's in singapore it's
being broadcasted in america at our time
on amazon so it's a big deal for one
championship man and they're bringing
out the big boys yeah fun [ __ ] card
man big boys and it's in singapore that
super stadium it's gonna be lit it's
gonna be dope so check it out it's on
amazon that's this friday the time is
tough so in singapore it is december out
there i think right now
let me look so the dj mirage card that's
on saturday it says saturday august 27th
8 am sgt so if anyone you guys can do
the math at home you can figure that out
um let me see
so
here's my boys i want championship josh
she said the lead card starts at eight
eastern main card strips at 10 eastern
so that's 7 p.m pacific
boom
7 p.m pacific and for the 20 the big boy
yeah for the for the
so tune into that kid those tune into
that it's gonna be quite the spectacle
and that's on amazon prime you gotta
have amazon if you have amazon what the
hell you doing so this is another reason
to get amazon prime you can watch
mariah's vs johnson 2 and all the big
names i just mentioned and that's on
amazon prime you get the legend the uk
legend liam harrison you got all sorts
of [ __ ] going on you got bushesha it's
just fun fights man hey gary oh yeah
hagerty's one of my favorites here it is
an absolute [ __ ] savage man
love hey gertie you know hatred he might
be my favorite guy on the card
nice
all right jim what do you got all right
let's go here oh also over the weekend
was
anthony joshua oh my god that's how
that's how crazy this weekend was i
wouldn't forget about joshua alexander
you sick
going into this fight you know joshua
took some time got with uh
mikey garcia's brother to be his um
trainer
but if you watch the first fight against
usake who's from [ __ ] ukraine who's
obviously dealing with a lot over there
um it was a it was a matter even though
u6
i was especially now you look at the
monsters you look at um you know joshua
wilder uh fury
um you look at the big boys pulav like
they're big boys
um using isn't a big boy he's about 220
218 so you know he relies on his skill
you're talking about you know a guy who
you know gold medal winner in the
olympics yeah [ __ ] as skilled as they
get man and uh
you know
their first fight he completely
outskilled joshua and i think joshua
kind of overlooked them and uh that
doesn't matter um because joshua didn't
overlook him in the second fight and
there's not enough hours in the day to
make up for the technique that usyk
brings and he just dominated him now
they had a split decision i think that's
uh the uk being friendly
you know i i think
um that's the the uk judge is being
friendly there
but yeah josh was never going to win
that fight it was interesting too i
don't think it's helping joshua you know
it's usyk's time he grabs the mic and
goes on the rant so this article in
particular they're talking about how he
seems kind of out of character
and when you actually watch the whole
thing
it's like
joshua's giving us props but giving him
props because like to beat someone like
me it's like it's he's kind of like
building himself up yeah and he's kind
of when he's like a lot of people say oh
you're not like you know uh this old
school fighter this fighter he's like
i'm big man i'm whatever 40 stones or
the [ __ ] is i don't know stones he's
like you know why don't you throw more
combos because i'm big man like bro
you've lost two in a row now why are you
on the ma this is not your moment but i
know it's uh get into the [ __ ] locker
room hit the showers get in the gym work
on your technique
no one's falling off harder than
anything joshua
i'd love to see him versus wilder and
now he'd definitely be more open to it
yeah oh
i have it somewhere but wilder's also
going to fight again
i don't know his opponent
but we'll go we'll cover that in a bit
though but yeah joshua seemed a little
odd here he dropped two of his belts
the whole thing was weird i just don't
think his heart's in anymore i think
he's made more money than god you know
he's the most famous fighter on the
planet most highest selling fighter
maybe not more than canal but right up
there and i just think you know he's too
fat and happy and
those days are done using dodging bomb
still training legit he's awesome dude
he's a character too
so kamar osman this is a statement after
he lost
uh come on said champs [ __ ] up sometimes
but we bounce back come with vengeance
hashtag nightmare
yeah yeah yeah this can be a very tough
[ __ ] fight for lyanna versus the
rematch
yeah
and that's this that was his first ever
real
ko right usman
like knocked out cold oh yeah yeah so
that's good he's never even been dropped
yet i think yeah yeah so edward said
like let's see how he returns after that
because that's a huge deal when that
happens you're going to learn a lot
about kumar usman
does it waiver his confidence stuff like
that
yeah i thought this was really cool this
is between uh rock hold and dc and
they're super close yeah
yeah luke just getting blood on
everybody
that was such a
it was so weird but it was actually kind
of cool too to see that
but uh yeah anyways
there's just a bunch of fighters talking
about the let me see let's go through
them all right here we go uh so want to
play say you don't know where i've been
lou
there's a movie scene where someone's
like spitting blood at someone's face
uh there's terrorists because for kenny
shout out to him but rocco just did some
psycho rockstar [ __ ] and smeared his
blood all over paulo's face yep we saw
dude um france but three years out of
competition not three months but luke
rockhold held through then before hung
up his glove congrats
all right al jamaica what a scrap looked
like a crazy adrenaline dump
on both sides early but they both kept
pushing congrats to rockhold on a great
career let me know if you changed your
mind at some point frank mayor just
clapping emojis
cub great yep
ben asking but why was he just running
blood all over what the [ __ ] never seen
that before agree
um that's your guts proud of you
yeah anyways
but that was really bizarre but it was
quite good i'm [ __ ] old that's funny
this is uh costa reacting to it
let's go watch it real quick
[Music]
he goes lip to lip i know it's so trippy
dude and it looks like kosta's smiling
too i think he's like what the [ __ ] i
know it's funny
um
anyways costa basically said he had to
take a long shower after that yeah it
was kind of nasty and luke put i've been
through so much the last years
thank you thank you fighting to ufc
thank you joe i can't [ __ ] do this
anymore i give it my all and it just
didn't i'm [ __ ] old yeah that was
super funny but he kind of you know
usually the thing is to leave your
gloves in the octagon yeah but he took
him i know so and then uh
this says joe rogan put it perfectly
well luke i'll tell you what you have
you have heart and courage like no one
else that was amazing display of
perseverance and guts and courage and
the will to win and it was awesome to
watch and if this is the last fight you
have inside out gun thank you very much
for incredible career yeah shout out to
rock hold one of the best middleweights
of all time in his prime
savage and like i said his grappling is
like insane
all right this is before the fight luke
kind of was i don't know if he's out of
character but he does he's never gone
this hard on the media and people and
ufc dana i think he knew like this was
his last hurrah so he's like [ __ ] it
let's burn the house down so this is him
talking about a media member i think
he's from
like like full sandbox yeah with one of
those guys
you have carte blanche because i know
you're in business with dana
you gotta do your [ __ ] homework
you [ __ ] you know the degenerate
culture of [ __ ] bar still sports and
full sin is that you got to do your
homework you can't approach cheeto and
give him a [ __ ] mexican mask about
his culture
his culture he's [ __ ] ecuadorian
[ __ ] and luke and cheetah are
super close
it wasn't
to do with his background this guy's
like
san diego bro no but you gave him a
mexican mask and you said that this is
your culture like you're wrestling it
just said something along those lines
in disrespect it was a disrespect to him
and where he's from
it's about being a reporter it's about
doing your homework
and really understanding
what you know you guys got carte blanche
because dana's [ __ ] partner with you
guys right now but [ __ ] do your
[ __ ] homework and grow a better
culture so just stop getting stopped
giving bad culture to kids
basically just went off on about that
yeah i'm not mad at it
it's hilarious too yeah and also he
talked about fighter pay
i'll play a little bit of this
root against me for what
what are they gonna do i mean root
against me go for it do your thing dude
i'm here to fight
i'm not saying anything that's not real
everything i'm saying is justified and
truthful just because like i should be
in a position of power before i say this
[ __ ] [ __ ] off
i don't need this business
it's just like you know i i love
fighting
and i'm here to fight the best
[ __ ] and this happens to be the
place where it's done
you know
the company is [ __ ] growing and
they're implementing other little stupid
ass bonuses five thousand dollars here
five thousand dollars there fifty
thousand dollars man we've been stuck on
this [ __ ] for [ __ ]
20 [ __ ] years i mean back when gsp
fought jake what was that 100 000 it's a
great [ __ ] there was growing there
was there's a little yeah yeah this
point is only gotten bigger but the
bonus stays it actually went down
because a thousand dollars for yeah jsp
and jake shields
so of course francis and gone are chimed
in and france is like ooh say laps
uh listen luke's interview is very
pertinent uh a lot of things that
nobody's talking about because just
rolls with it partners are ripped off
with sponsorship is huge source of
revenue
um i understand the sport needs to look
good with uniforms but we should at
least have a right for a minimum of two
approved sponsors i agree yeah i agree
last year i lost a deal over a million
dollars from a crypto exchange because
the partnership with crypto.com what do
i got from it yeah nothing right
yeah
uh this is dana responding to luke's
this is interesting so
yeah so dave responds luke rockhold was
above and beyond taking care of the
issues that he had here i don't give a
[ __ ] what health uh plan you have they
would have never covered the things that
we covered for luke rockhold that's not
true uh
he's talking about [ __ ] i assume he had
a real bad issue with his leg uh
everything was absolutely [ __ ]
gibberish and absolute [ __ ]
yeah dana's in a tough spot you know um
did you have a guy talking about nobody
else has the balls talking about this
francis kind of doing it but you know
isn't going to do it to the level that
luke is obviously english in his first
language
um
you know but
it's just a matter of time for dana has
to address this the shame in all this is
you know luke didn't win and didn't go
on to become world champion because then
he has even bigger platform to ear this
stuff out
when you do do this the the ufc is going
to make sure you know you you get uh you
know
kind of silent
they put a silencer on you like
you know you're not going to see luke on
any you know post-fight shows or
pre-fight shows or
um
ufc has their ways man they have their
ways and they make it very tough for you
so
yeah you know i i appreciate what luke
did and it you know it's a good thing
and i wish more fighters would do it
but i understand why they don't because
you're going to get reprimanded and
you're not giving you the fight you want
and earn the money that you can for your
family or get the big names to get the
shine so
the chips no matter who you are not
stacked with you yeah going against it's
got to suck to do that i mean look at
woodley you know and even willie's like
i'd regret yeah about that like it it
really puts a damn brand career because
it's it's similar you know with lebron
if you
notice when lebron
plays for the lakers when when they lose
a game
lebron's not on the the
the main pictures it's always somebody
else i don't know if you guys notice
this when lebron loses a game for the
lakers it's never lebron he's always a
different player so he's a different
starter somebody else missed a shot it's
never lebron when they win it's always
lebron
when they win or they do something they
highlight something it's always lebron
well what you guys don't realize is
lebron's such a business savvy
surrounded by business savvy people he
has his own media outlet so he gets out
in front of his team controls the
narrative to make sure that you're
viewing lebron a certain way the ufc is
the exact same way and they're with
disney you're not gonna win it
you're not gonna
when i trust i
i left showtime cbs huge huge
there's certain advantages to being with
those big companies playing ball
that even if you're a youtuber like me
or you know as far as sponsorships
they're
they're going to do certain things to
make sure that your views are higher
than others
i'll leave it at that
but they can make it very tough for you
in many many ways that you guys don't
even think about
so lebron's team
will paint will have a narrative come
out before anything else so it doesn't
it's not a black guy in lebron ever
notice nothing his team controls what
you see
same as our politics i won't even go
down that rabbit hole but it's very
similar with politicians a lot of this
stuff now you can search it and find
that stuff this isn't conspiracy
anything like this
but you got to realize with with youtube
when when you do leave a big corporation
which i've done several times
you're you're you're
fighting
i guess we'll save the good fight
you know
and then okay heavy
i realize the crown you're in a fight
man we're in a fight thick boys in a
fight
it's a constant fight
it's a constant fight
i'll leave it at that yeah we'll leave
it at that
um so luke gold is doing the lord's work
but watch how much luke rockhold pops up
after this on major outlets unlike
things the ufc can control now we pop up
on on think boy or submission radio or
mma fighting sure sure but as far as
those big boys you'll never hear from
him again they'll silence him
so he goes okay so despite all that
stuff that happened luke was you know
saying his grievances before the fight
but afterwards you know dana white said
it was gibberish but after the fight
with costa dana white did appreciate
that so he did say something nice too
we're all called about here he's
entitled his own opinions uh to his own
opinions and his own i said it on twice
he's been taught his own opinions and
his own whatever it is that went on this
week
but let me tell you what i'll never say
anything about him i totally respect him
and after that war tonight normal humans
like us that are sitting in this room
have no idea what those two went through
tonight i'm not gone we never well thank
[ __ ] god
i thought dana had ct from kickboxing uh
for both of uh i love when people see
that uh for both of them to dig as deep
as they did put an absolute dog fight
like they did nothing but respect both
them uh they both
are they both a little nutty absolutely
but hey nothing but respect
sounds cool instead hold my tongue i'm
gonna hold my tongue why he doesn't go
after luke rock cold
that's for luke's book oh i know what
you're talking about that's good for
luke's book hello
of a hole in my tongue bros right bros
um all right so i don't know what you're
talking about i know so during the
weigh-ins
so paul acosta said [ __ ] usada
yes apparently they came in at 6am 6am
and they've done it before to guys like
4 a.m like before fights use mention
yeah are you out of your [ __ ] mind
usada come on dude figure it out that's
how you know these people are just nerds
never competed before
there's nothing more important than
[ __ ] sleep before a fight it's so
important and weight cutting too like
it's so important dude so for paulo
costa who came out and said this you
know and oozman also had an issue with
it so many fighters have issues with it
and then dana was like yeah that's never
happened again you know like you're
[ __ ] up the product you thought hey
hey usada we own you
you saw his employee of the ufc right
you guys know that right so
again not gonna get into it but uh you
know so dana can be like hey don't test
guys before 8 am you said he goes yes
yes master yes master that's how that
works
yeah that's not cool man
even if we're not even fighting someone
wakes me up at freaking four oh six a.m
to test you like
they text me hey flight leaves it like
what the hell i'll do [ __ ] it's 4am
eastern that's 1am your time you think
you feel sick now
bastards oh here's drake pretending he
knows mma i know so
he's paid to do this so he bet 240k
on jose aldo and of course jose lost
so
apparently he lost 430 thousand dollars
worth of money but um like you said
before
it's all part of the thing yeah that's
the way it works kids so uh they give
him they go hey drake here it's drake's
i don't [ __ ] know here's 15 million
pretend you're betting
also we'll do the bets for you because
we know you don't know [ __ ] about ufc
now i'm sure he's a fan of it and
watches it but in general come on what
are you doing as far as like betting no
no big big money on it yeah
you have to know it pretty well now one
of these benefits like hey shop what the
[ __ ] dude i took your draftkings priorly
using shop shop show
promo code i lost 400 000 betting on all
the dogs dumbass then it's real i'm like
okay now he knows what he's doing yeah
there's a quick one of course kayla
harrison she fought over the weekend she
won what poor girl got beat up by kayla
harrison martina jindrova that's cool
and then she does the whole thing on the
mic but
um let me see it okay i gotta see it i
thought it was a little odd is it a
little cringey for me
she was just imploring the crowd asking
is it too much to ask for a usa champ
are you gonna get this crowd to do a usa
champ hey
what's up everybody london
listen
you guys know a couple things about
queens right you got a queen over here
yeah
listen i'm here to tell you that i am
the queen
not of pfl
not of the 155 pound division i am the
queen of women's mma and if those three
brazilians will take out their track
shoes and need me then you'd find out
i'm not mad at that [ __ ]
well i'm not too cringey
standing in front of you
you want to go right now
[Applause]
it won't happen right now but it will
happen later this year is there anything
you guys see is so tight
i've been there bro
get tailored
you're on keto green cake i gotta get
back in soon coming through like a
goddamn train let's go
yeah
i remember
at um the other studio when she walked
in i was like oh my god dude she could
just destroy she's dope too yeah yeah
it's cool yeah she's dope
uh yeah the problem is you know she's of
course she's in the efl yeah she signed
up in the contract and until she starts
doing those cross-pollination fights
get your money girl that's what she's
doing you know probably buying
houses yeah just making bank yeah but
yeah
what you can do you know
what the girl should be what's girl
before that's your favorite i don't know
before that should be i just read the
name too yeah i mean it's it could be
the girl made my starbucks drink i don't
know
stack that paper though yeah [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah get yours i'm a fan
uh shane burgos he
he was on his last fight he won and now
he's out of the ufc he went to the pfl
and dana white actually says i don't
think he's said this before but he
actually regrets
like not fighting to get shane to stay
on
stay in the ufc yeah he's a fun fighter
it shows you how big of a
corporation these become where they just
didn't address shane burgos they're so
busy
he's on his last fight i'm sure his
team's hit up the ufc like yeah we'll
get to it he's like okay well i gotta
fight dude so i get to make money i'm
gonna sign with the pfl and they just by
the time they got there he signed with
him yeah that's how busy there
i mean you know shane burgos is you know
they definitely made a mistake there um
to ufc's credit they'll be okay yeah
they'll be fine you know it's not like
you know trust me if that's connor nate
or [ __ ] hamza they would figure it
out but unfortunately for shane burger
who's such an exciting fighter good
person yes you know brings it every time
just got overlooked part of the probably
one of the problems being part of a big
conglomerate with tons tons and tons of
fighters yeah yep
this is pretty dope tony ferguson i love
this fight i saw this this is on uh the
nade diaz card september 10th yeah i
think so great fight dude
lee jingling tony ferguson yeah take my
[ __ ] money baby that's a great
awesome yeah i would not expect that so
that's his move up to 170 for fergie
ferguson ferguson yeah
dreamland that's a tough fight for tony
fun fight though yeah you can definitely
win that for sure jingling biggest face
in the world he's got he's got like a
nice mandible jaw oh i'm jealous man i
still didn't get those shots you talked
about you wanna you want it smaller
though yeah yeah well uh this is also
interesting robbie lawler versus sanchez
ufc 282. possibly needs to win so bad
yeah robbie lawler's legend he you know
the certain guys get past the certain
threshold where it's like i don't know
win lose draw i don't give a [ __ ] he's
like we could fight every saturday
possible needs a goddamn win though
yep and uh speaking of nate diaz and
hanzad so dana white's saying that if
nate wins you could potentially get a
title shot
what do you think of that
i mean what's that cun i mean i mean
because comes like basically is number
two i think what's going on right now is
dana's doing damage control being like
you who are doubting nate man you're out
of your mind it's like bro he's a
plus 2 200. what are you talking about
it's insane he's like
this is actually a very competitive
fight buy it you know no i'll buy it for
sure i'll buy it for sure now
anybody knows a sport knows nate's a
tough character to get out of there and
you know i'm definitely putting money on
him in case he pulls something off but
dana let's call what it is all right
you're throwing them to the [ __ ]
chechnyan via sweeting goddamn dragons
okay
and it is what it is
and then we talk about title shot
i mean he could data might as well say
i'm going to give nate diaz the ufc if
he beats hamzat you know it's like i'm
going to give him the ufc what do you
mean he's going to own the ufc if he
beats hamza he could say what he's this
is such a [ __ ]
throwaway for him to make sure that
people keep giving him [ __ ] over booking
nate diaz and hamza that's all this is
it's just him playing damage control
yeah he's gonna get a title shot really
it's his last finance contract things to
fight [ __ ] jake paul for 40 million
what are you talking about
it's just damage control yeah it's all
good so
and there's other like
mma analysts that are saying that dude
this is is
this is one of the worst things you
could ever do like they're actually
seriously concerned about nate diaz's
health
i get it yeah hell yeah yeah yeah most
people who aren't in the pockets are
like that yeah
uh so i think this is the same car too
so jon jones
tweeted this
ufc 282
bro i'm ah
if they book [ __ ] jon jones steep 8
on [ __ ] ufc 282 i'm jacking off to
the card yeah i'm gonna pull my big
spotted dick out and jack off
and that's what you say yeah and on only
fans
scary goes i'm not even gonna bother
getting my hopes up i'm hurrying man i
hear you just gonna put this
undefeated but uh johnny loki means ufc
382
[Laughter]
boy man this guy was he's gonna have two
more duis by december [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
yeah oh my god if he's on 282
i know well then homs.net diaz isn't
your main event can't be john john stipe
you're made of dude there's nobody i
want more on the efc card than jon jones
he's the best to ever [ __ ] do it he
just needs to embrace this [ __ ] joker
character and say [ __ ] everybody yeah
dude i like to party yeah i don't have
to train as hard as everybody and i can
beat anybody in the [ __ ] world at 205
at 205 plus [ __ ] bring it
he's divorced now
living alone [ __ ] it hungry hungry what
are you gonna doubt jon jones that's
something i've never i've made a lot of
mistakes in my life i've never doubted
jon jones ever
he's the best dude
it's gonna be so exciting him verstipe
ambrose jon jones
[ __ ] off yeah
i wonder why i put 282 that means
they're trying to figure it out that's
like soon too so super soon and then
uh i bet you he does um
[Music]
hmm
oh so hamza
and nate diaz is ufc 280 so
oh no ufc 282 would be december
december so yeah so he'd be the main man
that 100
because you would the ufc if they
announced john they're gonna need time
to they're not gonna do him september
10th they don't have enough time
yeah what am i saying okay yeah yeah so
so that would be
um boy or some big boy fight they even
bypass it here so after the style bender
peja card
it's not on there yet not yet you know
why it's not on there they're waiting
for stipe yeah that's what's popping
daddy that's like freaking dope oh i
can't wait
gosh there's some big boy fights
oliveira maca chef uh ufc 280 izzy
pierra
you got a lot of money in that fight
man it's gonna be sick
all right uh let's go here dominic griez
he's been out for a while so he's a
return against ryan spann that's a good
five two and a really good
fight and this one we kind of expected
to call esparza and zhang willi to fight
for carla
ufc 281 yep
and let's bypass that one oh so gilbert
burns is saying that um he's verbally
agreed to fight rory mazdal but they're
just waiting for it here's the thing
take it from your boy here i verbally
agreed to fight mark hunt and the i got
a text from david said that's not how
this works oh
yeah yeah they go we'll take it from
here yeah that's not what we want to do
[ __ ]
i said say last dude throw me that
revocate
yeah
you guys did it behind the scenes to you
and hunt
oh no no we did it uh publicly okay yeah
on twitter just talking [ __ ] each other
and dm he was like
i was like hey big fan man i'm not no
disrespect because now i'm down to knock
you out i'm like so aggressive
so aggressive dude his resurgence was
insane yeah thank god that's in fruition
type move dana
so
we all know this already paige transant
was pulled
apparently from bkfc last weekend this
last week she's gonna be on the denver
card i think there's the other they're
trying to plan it for that denver place
but i mean she doesn't she said it it
wasn't her it was them and it was
apparently some sort of logistics issue
like no one knew exactly what's going on
there was rumors that the ticket sales
were low but then apparently that's not
really the case i don't know i'm not
sure um so my mma news not yet confirmed
but here in rooms that page that has
been pulled from this week's bkfc london
fight card due to low ticket sales
i mean they're probably like we're not
going to waste page vans in on this
let's just move over to the yeah there's
so many fights that freaking saturday
dude so many yeah
yeah makes sense
um it says initial report talked about
low ticket sales but now hearing issues
from paige's side yeah so i no one's
like
there's no clear answer here i'm not
sure what happened
but that's what she wrote on here yeah i
can't imagine paige um going through
camp cutting weight and then backing
down
that's that's not paige
your dude bro beau nichol he's gonna
return
versus a guy named donovan beard
for the september 27th dana white
contender series i went home the pain
for bone nickel he enjoyed it he
commented on the video he did and then
big
i like how he says it here
i'm back sometimes
and bow nickels continuously that's what
i'm saying bo bro you should be the face
contender series become the first ever
contender champ get some experience
there and then jump to the ufc
the problem with that is all the young
uh talent is gonna get absolutely
annihilated and so we can't build
anybody else but i'm on bo nichols trade
yeah
um
so this
i guess ufc is doing watch parties now
well and uh
remember what the stuff i didn't want to
get into keep going yep so gronkowski
and i guess they had kevin holland on
and they had some fun
someone in the ufc office is just
watching take away your own fight
companion yep we can do that and flash
tonight
that's cool we'll take that as well with
the skylar bros who absolutely love no
shade on them okay we'll take that and
then not only are we gonna do that we're
gonna make it better because they can
actually use our fight footage okay
there we go
what else is he doing fighter on the kid
they copy that
i love i love matt sarah and and jim
norton too but yeah definitely
yeah
just saying
it's claire's day yeah this is this i
find it flattering it's cool yeah yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] what are you gonna do
can't stop that stuff
so this is a max holloway going on a
jet
and he actually passes out here oh yeah
he's finally knocked out yep
i wouldn't uh
i would do this i was about to say i
don't know if i would do this
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it does sounds like he's about to
get sick
see i i get sick
i have
they're trying to knock him out
yeah i would throw up myself
[Music]
oh damn he passed out
do you think that was their goal
[Music]
it's like top gun
[Music]
let's get it
i'll do that
have you passed that before or no
never i mean i've been knocked down no
no i mean like no never have you yeah
from what drinking i don't know what it
was for like twice in my life i've like
fainted really yeah never not once
that's good i've had in oh well they
call it vertigo yeah i get that all the
time i got that because i took
too much of some supplement and then i
went hiking with my pops at like high
altitude so something with caffeine
maybe yeah and then i sat down and i
went to get up and i was like oh the
whole room was like you just can't move
like you get up you just talk yeah you
don't have to never pass out though
yeah passing out is freaky
yeah i can't be healthy no not good all
right so this is uh deontay wilder
announcing his fight you're looking
skinny the bronze from wilder and i'm
proud to announce that i have a
pay-per-view fight october the 15th
and it's at a place dear to my heart
call it my second home that's in
brooklyn at the cylinder i saw him right
there right back to barclay center or a
place where i have my most electrifying
knockout my most devastating knockouts
and my most rememberable times in my
career and i'm looking forward to
returning the king has returned and
we're going to be right there at the
barclays center hey tickets are on sale
now and you can purchase those tickets
at
seatgeek.com that's s-e-a-t
g-e-e-k
dot-com so go get your tickets right now
you don't want to miss this show you
know while the tickets last and i'll see
you guys there
so a guy named helenius lanny's about to
get [ __ ] murdered
and that's his record
oh i mean it's not bad
yeah deontay wilder caliber
uh this is a sad one but tyson fury i
guess in the uk like there's like knife
attacks
things
i know but still dude
nice but knives compared to guns i know
but still
i don't know good i'm just saying
i'd rather trade that problem for our
problem so apparently his cousin was
killed over a night
killed by a knife attacked that's
horrible yeah so he just plead for yeah
that's when you get to do something
horrible
yeah
all right let's uh go oh this is i
thought it was interesting so we were
talking about hagerty earlier so this is
just
i guess watching him spar
hit pads and he looks pretty good
[Music]
hell yeah he looks [ __ ] good
[Music]
hey
yeah pretty badass jesus christ savage
and um oh keep i think this might be the
last one so this is a promo
this is hold on this is the promo to the
utah card that just happened ufc
and uh i did cringe but let me know what
you think
a lot of people liked it though
i love salt lake city we're sure you do
luke let's take a look at everything
salt lake has to offer enjoy some skiing
in park city
whoa sick moves jose
[Music]
wow i don't know utah is so beautiful
wow
incredible how about this local weather
mate that's right look at those
beautiful landscapes perfect for a hike
or a leisurely stroll around salt lake
thank you
you're welcome paulo but that's not all
all right i'm here in salt lake city
let's go check out some of the wildlife
moose sheep bison home
and did we mention our world famous
great salt lake
perfect for a swim with family and
friends and i'm sure you've heard of our
utah jazz
[Applause]
[Music]
and if you need to pray you're in luck
because we've got churches
[Music]
to enjoy
he must be talking about ufc 278 is
there a way we can watch
espn
[Music]
wow
well that's all the time we have today
folks sounds like we should tune into
that fight
wow i like this okay
i like it because it because they were
leaning into the cheesy i guess if it
was meant to be like not a major problem
yeah yeah i don't know i just cringe but
i mean people seem to like i dig it yeah
all right kids that's it you got the big
one championship this friday 7 p.m
pacific time you have mariah johnson ii
you also got nango liam harrison the uk
legend you got uh ruth tang on there you
got bushesha marcus almeida you have
great fights man you got jonathan
hagerty my fave on the card you also got
anjali's brother fighting on the earlier
card so it's pac-man but you gotta get
it at amazon prime you want championship
is here they're here to take over
america baby so make sure you check it
out get git
prime
amazon prime and you can watch the card
there all right
um other than that man fun time check
out both fight companies the one with
bert uh i was one probably my favorite
fight companion ever so you got bert
kreischer matt matrion myself breaking
down bkfc really would talk about
everything but watch the main event and
then you got the ufc 278 with sam
tripley bradley martin uh
matt matriona and myself as well
available right now at thick boy youtube
go check out both of them it's a fun one
the food truck diaries with angela lee
and rich franklin drops wednesday which
i think you guys will enjoy i was forced
to eat healthy with rich franklin who
looks phenomenal at his age um as far as
tour life goes man still coming to
chicago um and you can run the tough
mudder with me august 27th saturday the
tough mudder run 15k they have 10k 5k
but if you want to run with the thick
boys we do the 15k it's 11am startup
time use promo code team brandon get 10
off sign up go to toughmudder.com right
now look at click on the chicago link
you'll see the thick mutter on there
come running with me and the thick boys
will be so much fun chicago i'll see you
out there um i have shopping friends
august 31st that's a wednesday in l.a at
the hollywood improv shop and friends
one show only with [ __ ] monsters 8 pm
show and then uh the real trash panda
tour starts whole new hour appleton
wisconsin september 8th through the 10th
ontario california ontario improv my
favorite clubs ontario improv is
september 15th through the 17th and then
we end
uh
the summer tour in boston that's
september 29th october 1st i think
summer's officially over september 22nd
but either way uh the last one in
september is in boston laugh boston want
to get my reps in not doing the big
theater in wilbur decide to do a club i
can't [ __ ] wait laugh boston boston
massachusetts is september 29th through
october 1st get your tickets right now
baby thickboy.com we're also dropping
new merch this friday we have nba
quality thick boy jerseys nba quality
thick boy shorts and a new dope thick
boy hat i think you guys will dig it and
you can also get the tie-dye just
re-upped that so all new sizes are back
in the trucker hat the long white shirt
you always see me wear the tanks all
that
re-ups with the new nba quality
basketball jersey shorts and hats that
drops friday at 9am pacific at
thickboy.com all right um
appleton wisconsin you're up next baby
you're up next and then it's off to
ontario improv ontario california then
boston thickboy.com love you guys hope
you enjoyed it like subscribe do all
that fun stuff see you next time stay
thick 12-time world champion demetrius
johnson makes his much anticipated taboo
at one championship
the one the long way
champion
well obviously i'm the number one good
tenor i got a date with adrian maurice
a world title showdown for the flyweight
gold
well adriano said demetrius was
dominating ufc i was dominating one
championship
cj's hunt
adriana marias defeats demetrius johnson
everybody knows who is the best in this
division
if you know you know if you did it you
know now
okay what i can take a knee to the jaw
get right back up
the rematch we've all been waiting for
you